ils sont partis sans laisser de trace
vers le moyen orient des québécois des
ontariens des albertains qui les a
recrutés qui les a aidés stéphane
berthemet explique dans son livre la
fabrique du djihad comment les réseaux
sociaux peuvent faciliter la
radicalisation des jeunes
j'ai fait une expérience empirique et je
suis parti vraiment en disant je vais
voir ce que ça va donner
j'ai créé deux comptes j'ai créé un
compte sur facebook et un compte sur
twitter des comptes avec un prénom d'un
jeune d'un jeune homme que j'ai inventé
de toute pièce je voulais voir ce qui
allait lui arriver quand il allait
justement abordé les questions de
terrorisme ou de radicalisation sur sur
les réseaux sociaux et rapidement on lui
a répondu